[Music]
Hey chuckling is hard yeah this has been
harder than setting up logging and
monitoring for my cloud infrastructure
actually if you use stackdriver it's a
piece of cake
what's that stackdriver is a tool that
lets you monitor and get insight into
your applications sounds useful how do
we get started let me jump right into a
demo
okay to start things off we're gonna
take a instance that I've just set up
here and go ahead and install Apache and
PHP into it as a kind of a basic example
so I'll go ahead and ssh into this and
this is just a brand new small instance
i've set up that i haven't done anything
with yet but we want to make sure that
we actually have something to monitor of
course using stackdriver you kind of
want to monitor and log different events
that are going to come out of in this
case the default linux properties but
you know you can easily configure that
to add additional logging we're just
going to except to the basics here so
I'll go ahead and install Apache and PHP
go ahead and let these update and once
those are done we'll make sure
everything looks good and then we'll
install the actual stackdriver agents so
nothing special here let these run
through okay well let's skip that 30
seconds and now that it's all set up
we'll go ahead and make sure everything
looks good by bringing up this in a new
tab and we can see there we go we have
it a chichi successfully installed so
now what we're gonna do is actually
install the agent itself we're gonna go
ahead and look at a quick script that
basically just grabs the different
agents the monitoring agent in the
logging agent and then installs them so
we'll go ahead and run those and while
that's happening we'll go ahead and take
a look at the stack driver interface
that'll probably take about a minute so
we know that Apache works and in the
Google Cloud console we can take a look
for stack driver now if this is your
first time setting up stack driver or
clicking on this monitoring link which
takes you to the stack driver interface
you may have to go through a small setup
process basically you're just going to
choose what GCP project you're using and
some other small setup steps that can
take another couple of minutes as well
but once you have that set up you can
easily just come to this interface and
switch projects like you might already
be
Miller with so once we kind of have
those logs installed we should be able
to go here to resources click on
instances and we should see that the
instance is set up right here you can
see another instance that I had set up
earlier but lamp instance is the one we
want to take a look at so I'll click on
that and you can see just by kind of
running that quick command line we have
the agent installed and it's already
monitoring some of the more standard
metrics that you might see on an
instance including CPU and memory usage
Network throughput these kind of things
so this is a great way to kind of just
quickly get that set up one of the other
great things you can do in stackdriver
is actually set up a dashboard so if you
go to dashboards and hit create
dashboard you can start to add charts
charts are basically these metrics that
you're going to be able to select from a
list here and kind of choosing your
instance get a better understanding of
creating a custom monitoring dashboard
for the metrics that you actually care
about one of the other important aspects
of stackdriver is going to be alerting
so by setting up an alerting policy we
can easily take a metric on an instance
and tell it tell staff driver to notify
us when something happens so if we go
ahead and add an example condition such
as our instance here we already have an
instance we'll pick our lamp instance
and we can go ahead and choose something
like if the CPU load average is above
80% that might be something that we're
concerned about because maybe that means
our web server is serving too much
traffic or some process is locked we'll
go ahead and choose that and then we'll
add the notification so here we can add
an email we can add an SMS a couple of
different integration options here there
are tons of things we can do and then in
documentation we can just add some
additional texts in case we want to set
up some more advanced monitoring or in
just in case we want to know you know
what kind of flag or what group this was
set to we can use that for custom text
name the policy and then save it and
that way we'll get notified in case
anything happens
now the next part we'll look at is the
actual logging so if we come here and
click on logging we can see the default
logging interface which is also using a
stack driver on this drop down here we
can choose what instance we want to look
at in our case we're going to look at
lamp instance and in the subsequent
filter we're going to go ahead and
choose syslog once we fit set that to
the filter we can see all the different
things that have been sent to syslog
just so that we can measure whatever
applications might be using or whatever
any other Logging's well anything that
gets sent to syslog really just like
that you can set up logging monitoring
and more great now I'll have a real grip
on my application in the cloud yeah only
it was that easy to learn how to juggle
[Music]
don't forget to comment like and
subscribe and if you want to get in
contact with us click on the link in the
description
[Music]